Welcome to the Anne and Ashley show.
I'm Ashley and I'm Anne.
We are here live at Conner's Clinic.
Make sure you share this video, subscribe,
like and follow our channel.
And today we are going to be discussing
our Fab Five Powdered Supplements.
So they range from gut health to brain support,
to detox, to overall wellness.
So each one of them serves their own purpose,
but together they make the fabulous five.
So Anne's going to talk to us first about
the gut health section of this combination.
Yes.
So these three here are more related to gut health.
And we talk about gut health a lot here
because it is foundational to health overall.
If you think about the external world
and then your internal body, so the gut
and the digestive tract is really the barrier
that separates the things from outside from your body.
And the cell that line your digestive tract,
it's only one cell thick.
So it's a very small membrane or barrier.
So we want to make sure that the lining of your gut
is very well intact.
A lot of people do have a leaky gut.
They're not eating healthy.
They're exposed to different toxins.
They might be eating foods that they have,
issues with causing an inflammatory response.
All of these things can create leaky gut symptoms
of a leaky gut.
It could be anything from any type of disease diagnosis.
It can be an autoimmune disease.
You can have cognitive issues.
You can have, I don't know, memory issues.
Anxiety, cravings for sugar in part.
So a lot of these things can be traced back to a leaky gut.
So these items here really help to improve
and maintain the integrity of that gut lining.
So there's your one cell thick lining.
And then you have this mucus layer
that houses all of the beneficial bacteria in your gut.
You need that healthy mucus layer
because we know that all of those healthy gut bugs
that we talk about, they perform functions
that are necessary for your body to work properly.
So the sun spectrum here is a prebiotic fiber.
And it's got probiotics in well.
So again, helping to maintain the integrity
of the cell or of the gut lining.
It's also got percuminoids in it.
So to help with an inflammatory response
and then it's got coq10 in it,
which helps with circulation and heart health.
The SBI Protect has, it binds two toxins
that are within your gut
and it helps your body remove them and eliminate them.
So this is more of a gentle kind of support
for the integrity of the gut.
Neither one of these have a taste.
So you really can mix them within a smoothie.
You can mix them with another product that has a taste.
So these are really mild and flavor.
And the greens first.
It's got, I believe it's 49 or 50 different super foods in here.
So it's a great way to just pack a huge punch
for nutrition, minerals, antioxidants support.
There's digestive enzymes in here.
There are some probiotics in here.
So if you think about today's world in which we live in
and we're so busy all the time,
it's hard to always eat fresh fruits and vegetables
every day in the quantity that we really need
to be eating them in.
So this can help get those nutrients into your body
so that your body and cells can work optimally.
This one here, this original flavor
has a hint of experiment taste to it.
So we do have other varieties.
There's a chocolate version or there's a berry version.
The experiment really isn't your jam.
So those are kind of my favorite.
I try to really these two.
I'll take a scoop of this and maybe a half spoon of that.
Mix it in.
I try to sit on it throughout the day.
So I'm getting a constant dose throughout the day
of all of the nutrients in here.
And then obviously they've got a health support.
So those are my favorite.
This one is a little more gentle.
This one, sometimes people have a little bit
of an issue with elimination if they use too much of this.
So this is just suggested to just start slowly with this
because of that fiber content.
And if you are sensitive, you might have
a little bit of an issue with that.
Like your gut super leafy.
Yeah.
Then it might be that, yeah, definitely.
Okay, so then we have these two.
And so this one, Pectus LC is a modified citrus pectin.
So it is known to be a gentle key later for our bodies.
So a key later is something that's going to pull
what doesn't belong.
So toxins obviously don't belong in our bodies.
We're exposed to them every day.
So what this does is it helps attach to them and find them.
And it prevents them from being adhesive
to being able to stick on anything else in your body.
So it helps eliminate them a lot more.
It's a gentle key later.
You can get some that are a little harder on your body.
So you have more maybe of a detox reaction to them.
But this in combination with that spirit protect
would really help someone just find the toxins
and get them out nice and gently.
And not really experienced too much of a reaction.
You might still have a detox reaction with this.
I know for me, I get just really warm.
I don't know why.
That's my detox reaction or sweating.
Like if I took a full scoop, I will like get really hot.
But otherwise, again with this,
you'd want to start small and see how your detox reaction is.
But I love it.
I think it's wonderful because they're exposed to everything
every day.
Also, people who have detox pathway issues in your genes,
this would be a really great product for you.
We have cosmetic toxins, household toxins.
Some of us get vaccinated.
We also have some people who take medication.
So those will still serve a purpose.
But then it's when your detox pathway is locked,
where it's no longer serving a purpose.
Because you should be able to utilize it
and then get rid of it.
It should have kind of an exploration in your body
with defects you aren't able to get rid of it
on your own, or as well.
So adding something to assist and bind to those toxins
and help your body flush them out a lot quicker
is going to prevent damage long-term to yourself
as far as disease and illness goes.
So this, anybody can take.
Kids can take dogs and cats can take.
So I thought that was pretty cool.
They get vaccinated too.
And so adding that into their regimen
don't think I'm gonna hit me or I'm weird about that.
But I think I'll turn to if you're a dog care.
Why not?
Sure.
And if you think about so many people get their yard sprayed,
and then we have these animals that I mean,
my dog is on this town, she's around and covered in it
by the entrance to the gray house, right?
So bring it onto your home.
Don't spray.
Number two, if you do, then you just have to be mindful
and really these can help support most detox pathways.
Yeah, so this is great.
No taste really.
I mean, it comes from like the pith of the citrus fruits
of lemons and oranges.
But regardless, there's no really a taste to it.
So you can totally mix it with something else.
The OptiMeg Neural is actually called ClareNeg Neural.
The Dr. Connor's brand here.
So this is going to be full of magnesium,
which we need magnesium for so many reasons.
But this one in particular has magnesium-alphaenate,
which is research-find it to cross our blood brain barrier.
That's great for people with sleep issues, anxiety,
people who want to perform better with memory and learning.
And it's also had research with Alzheimer's behind it
and helping them with their memory even.
And then students, college students,
going to school for these big exams.
This is something that they've used
and been tested really well for their cognitive excellence.
So, I think it's really convenient that.
Yeah, for sure.
Nothing's wrong with sleeping better.
So as far as sleep goes, I can take this during the day
and I can be just fine.
And I'll sleep like a rock at the end of the day.
She'll take it out work,
and be a little...
I'm wondering why.
I'm not sure because I slept all the time.
Yeah, so we keep this away from Anna at work.
And it's going to be nice when I'm in the home.
I'm in that home.
So this one is lemon lime.
And then we also have a mixed berry,
which both are very good.
Yeah, it tastes so good, which is what I was...
I'm trying to increase my liquid intake,
so I was drinking it at work.
Yeah, it's flavor.
It's just playing water.
It's like a sparkling, cool light.
It is.
It tastes really good.
Yeah, it is very workable.
I kind of was having too much.
Yeah, then, yeah, the magnesium, yeah.
Definitely crossed my blood brain barrier
and was shutting things down.
And it's sleeping out working.
I picked up the slack, don't worry about it.
Thank you.
I owe you.
So these two mix together, I really like
because then you get your peel it or your brain health,
but the power by, we can call it now,
is all five of these together.
So the gut health, I mean, multivigamin,
the detoxing and the brain support,
what's cool too is you can give all these to your kids.
So if you're worried about if they're junk food,
eaters, you just can't get good nutrition in them.
This is great.
This is great for their gut.
They're a weak, you get preventative even for them.
And then, helping them if they did have
a lot of toxic exposures.
This is going to be great.
Then brain health for a student.
Why not?
Some special, of course, anti-inflammatory properties,
especially in the gut, I love that piece.
Like, you don't think about the foods you're eating
and, like, cigarettes blasts.
Show you what your sense tip to for foods in a minute.
I might have those inflammation responses.
And you might not realize that.
So a lot of times, there's some clinical inflammation,
but the constant assault overall can have
lasting effects, long-term effects,
and can lead into other things.
And so, those tight junctions can come apart.
And then, if you've done your genetics with us,
we do talk about the FUT2 gene.
So if you have defects in the FUT2 gene, which is very common,
then these are great to support
that the FUT2 gene is what helps build that healthy,
mucus layer, again, for the digestive tract
in the microbiome.
The MTH bar is such a big deal.
We can just start with something so simple.
Like, so simple.
So simple.
So good for it.
So it makes me very happy to be able to do this.
So, police.
Yeah, so that in kids and you and anybody,
you know, really could benefit from all of these.
That's why it's our favorite, because we can just
pick one and know that it's doing something good.
So we're going to actually, we haven't made our drinks yet today.
So we're going to make ours right now.
So I use a full scoop of that clear, made narrow.
So that lemon lime.
And I use a full scoop of the SBI protect.
I'll show you.
Oh wait, we're going to keep this one away from Abby.
Yeah.
And we use that one.
It's only like three and a nice,
but we need more calories.
So we're going very good.
So I do a full scoop of the SBI protect too.
And I will do maybe a half scoop of the greens.
This is a smaller one.
So about a half scoop of the greens.
I'm going to do a full scoop because I don't have
my greens today.
Yeah, today.
I don't know if you'll...
I died then.
I couldn't sell it last night, but I did not.
I've been fasting.
I have not been fasting.
And the pectis will be fasting.
Fasting, using same thing.
I'm going to alternate next week's going to be my fast.
This week is fasting.
So I'm only going to do about a fourth scoop
of the pectis I'll see because she doesn't want to get
all sweaty.
Yeah, that's not it.
It's a couple of hours.
Yeah, we had this one.
You should do a full scoop.
Let's see what happens today.
And then sunscreen, I'm going to do a fourth scoop
because I don't take this regularly.
I take the SBI protect a little bit more regularly
than the sun spectrum.
This also has a fiber component too,
which is for looking for anti-inflammatory fiber.
This is perfect for you.
Ooh, here's the ash.
Mine's just a tower of powders.
But I like that you can add this in a smoothie.
Right.
So you'll just mix in until it dissolves for enough notes.
Yeah, for fresh juke, if you're a juicer.
Yeah, you could totally go in the juice.
You can even use this to make different things.
And yeah, I have put, well, really the berry kind.
I put in with plain yogurt.
Just give plain yogurt.
A flavor that doesn't have all the chemical sugars in it.
I haven't tried this one in a day now.
But I did make a mint chocolate mint cup type thing.
Oh, yeah, like a peanut butter cup.
Yeah, like a peanut butter cup.
Only I used this and it was mint, such as a mint.
That's awesome.
That was really good.
Like a couple drops of peppermint oil,
essential oil as well, to just kind of pump up
the peppermint flavor.
We love this one.
That was really good.
When we did the Le Croix.
And we got the carbonated water, which was really good.
But all of this is carbonated drink
and make it kind of bubbly and fun.
Just be creative.
Yeah, just make your supplements on.
Yeah, that was enjoyable.
And drink it with your bestie.
Cheers.
Let's see.
It is.
It's good.
It's refreshing mind the experiment flavor with one in line.
So that's just really good.
I like it.
My mind's just saying it's the experiment.
It just tastes really clean and refreshing.
Yeah, it does.
So if we had, I recommend this five here.
Yes, the fabulous five powders.
Yes.
So stay tuned for next time.
It may or may not be another drinking episode
of something evening drink.
Healthy evening drinks.
So day tuned for the next episode.
Thank you for watching.
Yes, and please share this video with your friends.
Like and subscribe so you don't miss.
You definitely not gonna want to miss next.
Next week, yes.
Oh, and we'll put links to these on the bottom of this as well.
Thanks for watching.
Bye.